Demain, si la Russie gagne en Ukraine,
si la Pologne est attaquée,
nous serons aussi attaqués. Et je voudrais que,
on clarifie,
euh, les uns et les autres, tous, notre position,
la Pologne est interpellée,
qui vous voulez interpeller à propos de cette position ?
C'est tout à fait
possible. Demain, c'est 1 risque qui est là aujourd'hui.
Et nous ne devons pas faire le jeu de la Russie.
Si vous voulez interpeller, et je crois ici,
autour de la table, monsieur Bardella, on sait
évidemment commence, qu'il y a,
oui, ça commence,
parce que vous avez des positions qui sont, euh.
Pour le moins euh.
Ambiguées, puisque évidemment
vous avez le soutien à la Russie qui est honteux
aujourd'hui.
Donc vous avez cherché à changer certaines de vos
positions, mais quand on regarde vos votes,
vous n'avez jamais,
Jordan Bardella, vous n'avez
jamais soutenu les condamnations
contre l'emprisonnement de l'opposant russe.
Jordan Bardella, votre réponse,
Jordan Bardella, vous avez même
confirmé sur votre liste 1 certain Thierry Mariani,
dont on connaît
les positions et la proximité,
ça fait beaucoup de choses.
Laissez Jordan Bardella
répondre, s'il vous plaît, au service,
non pas des intérêts de la France et de l'Europe,
mais des intérêts de la Russie